de actividades
vendido blumarine el icónico retrato de
andy warhol se vendió el lunes por la
noche por un precio de martillo récord
de 170 millones de dólares más de unos
25 millones de dólares en honorarios
son 200 millones ese era el precio
direccional llegamos a 195 creo que está
bien estás ok
[Risas]
hizo el retrato dos años después de la
muerte de marilyn en 1964 se inspiró en
una foto promocional de la película
niágara de la estrella de hollywood en
1953 una historia de infidelidad amor y
asesinato convertida en una de las
piezas más icónicas de warhol y un sello
de arte pop en mi patio ashton bone está
en mí sino en warhole y marilyn y si
piensan en ya sabes los precios de
warhol el récord de warhol estaba en 103
millones de dólares para el silver star
crush ya esto casi lo duplica y de nuevo
las obras de arte del siglo 20 obras de
arte estadounidenses es el precio más
alto jamás pagado spicer word gates el
retrato se ha convertido en la segunda
obra de arte más cara jamás vendida en
una subasta por detrás del salvator
mundi de leonardo da vinci que se vendió
por más de 450 millones en 2017 también
en christie's el icónico retrato de
warhol fue adquirido por un comprador no
identificado la recaudación se destinará
a una institución benéfica la fundación
tomás y doris samán que puso el cuadro
en subasta